ever wondered how the US Navy makes sure
their carriers can fling fighters like
this
well they sling eight thousand pound
sleds out to sea like this
whoa that's lunch skipped who wasn't
expecting that
I like skipping stones but this is a
whole nother level we went to the Naval
Air Warfare Center to ask Chief
Technologist Mike Doyle why he's driving
sleds also known as dead loads overboard
so a dead load is basically a hunk of
steel with wheels on it and it's meant
to replicate the weight of an aircraft
dead loads are cheap if anything goes
horribly wrong all you lost is a bunch
of steel the dead load is not designed
to skip because it actually causes
damage the dead load when it hits so the
tires get ripped off and there's a
damage to all the instrumentation so
this was a bit of a disaster
why did this let that's designed to sink
skip to get this sled to bounce you need
a lot of speed when it leaves the
aircraft carrier it's moving at a speed
of a hundred and fifty miles per hour or
240 kilometers per hour when the sled
makes contact with the water it's
exerting a huge force over a large
surface area very quickly and it doesn't
give time for the water to get out the
way and absorb that force so instead it
pushes back the sled comes in at a very
shallow angle and as a consequence most
of the slaves momentum is in the forward
direction rather than downwards so once
the water pushes a Slade in the air it
continues forward and thus it's skipping
across the water the system that has the
power to throw this heavy sled so fast
it's called emails the electromagnetic
aircraft large system this track is made
up of an array of electromagnetic coils
each coil is turned on or turned off in
sequence making sure that the coil in
front is pulling the sled forward while
the coil behind is pushing it forward
allowing the sled to accelerate rapidly
there is an incredible fun factor when
you're dealing with this is it is
basically a huge toy it is just
tremendous to watch these huge vehicles
up to a hundred thousand pounds and in
three seconds it's just gone so it's
just tremendous